like I think just making it exciting and
relatable to a young audience is so
necessary to get people like talking
about improving your credit score I mean
we talked about like really boring
things that's sibling
no one cares who's a teen about
improving your credit score but when you
say like you can you know buy these
houses you can have this lifestyle you
can like buy these things and have it
and this is what it means in the long
run if you just get a credit card and
pay it off on time like something like
that very few people are doing it
there's also I mean there's all it's
very it's very difficult sometimes to
navigate when that kind of content is
online because for example if I watch
any of your videos or most the time when
I watched a life for sale video the ad
that pop-up is a talking head talking
about how it can help you make X amount
of dollars per month and there's so many
of them out there
yeah there's a lot and and that's one of
the things unfortunately that I think is
and it's hard because I mean Ultraman a
lot of your videos are talking about you
the titles are how I made X amount of
dollars per month or I mean you know
obviously click play bait works to an
extent yeah but you know once you
actually like you know sometimes
clickbait people just have like a
[ __ ] detector that automatically
bypasses it or sometimes if they're
familiar with you i'd be familiar with
with you the character once they're
familiar with you they're gonna watch
your content no matter what thing I
definitely learned by doing YouTube
videos is what gets clicks and what
people want to watch and the sad thing
is if I say you know something like why
you need to set up a Roth IRA right no
one clicks on it but if you say you can
be a tax free millionaire by the time
you're 50 nine and a half
mmm everyone listens no one cares if I
say something like oh I got this new
credit card but when you say it's a ten
million dollar JPMorgan Reserve card
then people click on it no one cares
about making passive income they care
about how you make nine thousand dollars
a month in passive income like those are
the things that get people in the door
and then once they watch it and all of a
sudden it I think it opens their eyes to
what's possible yeah do you think
there's like a fine line you have to
dance when your content surpasses your
actual investment you're actually
investments or your knowledge of what
you're talking about because
I know there's I know of a few people
who in particular have a giant following
on like social media like Instagram
YouTube whatever and they may not be
practicing what they preach so to speak
so like so say you know you're following
it so big whatever your it's lucrative
you're making a living off creating this
entertainment online but what you're
talking about you may not necessarily be
doing anymore because you're making all
your money off off of the entertainment
that you're producing that's a very fine
balance yeah I'm very upfront that right
now I make more money doing YouTube
videos than I make as a real estate
agent I'm very upfront with that mm-hmm
and I think that's just the reality and
I really have to yeah do you want me to
take a break for good but I just think
that's the reality of making videos is
that at a certain point just because you
end up scaling up so quickly it just it
one day it becomes more lucrative so now
it's I really have to decide between if
I make let's say $1,000 an hour making
YouTube videos or make $600 an hour
selling someone a house where do I split
my time and my time is most valuable at
this point making YouTube videos
[Laughter]